today on our show News News News lots of
news or shooting news all over your face
like Spider Man shoots webs all over
Mary Jane space or Ned's Leeds face sure
equal-opportunity web shooting could be
either way today on fat man or men on
Batman or men or women or women welcome
back to another classic edition fat man
I'm Batman Kevin Smith muckman Garden
classic can't wanna not like back to the
old formula now that new form it's not
like crystal fat man in Batman no no
Crystal Pepsi here
no no whatsoever luck be a lady watch it
[ __ ] [ __ ] up a soda commercial not since
we burned Michael Jackson's hair off and
so poorly represented in the ad where
every 32 years we do something really
bad anyway [ __ ] Pepsi this is enough of
a free commercial for those guys yeah
[ __ ] yeah well they can eat they'll know
they could use though what's going on in
the world of news in our genre uncommon
boogie and that Manny and what's going
on we're gonna do an old-school new show
and you know the first news item hit me
it's about Batman hey the show's called
so that's good news it's about comic
books
hey that's our origin I don't know
Oregon story Scott Snyder Greg Capullo
great guys great couple of guys two
dudes who had a fifty issue sort of
redefining run on Batman for the DC's
this generations Batman Batman
are we uniting to to take on the entire
DC Universe with an event called Dark
Knight's metal band
that's kind of badass yeah yeah it
starts in August something look forward
to him I will read you from the press
release please tell which I copied from
the Internet oh yeah doing his homework
Providence I couldn't be more excited to
see Scott and Greg take on the DC
Universe said DC Entertainment publisher
Dan did to you about the project yeah I
know that guy
Hey Dark Knight's metal leans into the
strength of the relationship scott and
greg forged on batman to learn something
new and unexpected we're pushing the
world's finest heroes in new and
explored directions to tell a giant
story using all the characters in our
pantheon Snyder took pains to emphasize
that despite the title audiences
shouldn't expect Dark Knight's metal to
be to them a single talking oh man misty
swap even with terror nightmares it
won't be grim Snyder promised adding
that the story will instead be
celebratory huge and crazy I'm sitting
before I'm going for out of control
dinosaurs and lasers whoa whoa ladies
and gentlemen Scott Snyder wants some
dinosaurs he's gonna get them another
event after which comics will never be
the same
yeah cuz that's what they all do that's
what they do look it's got my vote I
like those guys and I just like to tell
entitle medal up the horns throw up the
horns I ask good piece of news Batman
related which is the title of the show
from the top back to the beginning can't
be honest with you man I'm looking at
the I'm doing the show for a while now
we have a guide to look at the calendar
for that crazy we haven't gotten in
trouble we have a word in our title that
we don't own someone else literally owns
that word and I'm not trying to you know
please don't [ __ ] us up is so far so
good but yeah I mean Marvel and DC at
some point went to court to defend the
copyright trademark on superhero it
belongs to them you can't use like if
you just a dude want to do a book that
has super he on it
you can't I wonder I wonder if I did the
fat man on spider-man how quickly I get
shut down by Disney gone fat man ain't
on spider-man nope
felt
you know he's on a generic [ __ ]
spider character but not our trademarked
copyright that we all just Dory des
neige ma'am in the movement doesn't
masters ma'am and him in the minute
ma'am and him in amount of metal mouth
all right so that's [ __ ] good news
we'll take that yeah in the Star Wars
universe oh we always like to hear news
from Star Wars you do indeed when we
lost Carrie Fisher not too long ago
there was there was a lot of a lot of
questions about whether or not she would
be or how involved Princess Leia would
be in the in movies episode eight last
Jedi an episode nine as yet untitled
given that she passed away after doing
production after completing principal
photography on the last Jedi but
according to her brother Todd she will
indeed appear in Star Wars Episode nine
he told the New York Daily News that he
along with Carrie's daughter Billie
lourd
gave the Disney permission to use recent
footage for the finale and it's
understood that no CGI would be used to
recreate Leia both of us were like yes
how do you take her out of it and the
answer is you don't Fisher said she's as
much a part of it as anything and I
think her presence now is even more
powerful than it was like obi-wan when
the Sabre cuts him down and he becomes
more powerful drop in lingo from within
the world he's speaking to the people
yeah he knows our language I feel like
that's what happened with Carrie I think
the legacy should continue I'm not the
only part of that equation but I think
the people deserve to have her she's
owned by them whoa Slave Leia that's
very sweet so that means when they say
existing footage they mean footage that
was shot that are outtakes on the
previous movie or interviews she did
like she was on Colbert you know I think
it could be anything and everything you
know my guess is that it's mostly stuff
that she had shot and they're just gonna
sort of parcel it out and we
contextualize it and drop backgrounds
and all that stuff but I don't I don't
think it's gonna be just you know like
from that documentary they're just
pulling photos oh but they could good
that's I'm sayin it's it just feels like
you know they're saying we don't want to
create our whole cloth that CG but don't
mean they can't sweet and Anderson
right using existing footage well that's
good yeah
so hey good news everybody yeah there's
Emily we get to see Carrie be Princess
Leia in the last of the saga movies but
don't kid yourself this ain't the end no
they're gonna make 19 more of these
they're gonna be like oh by the way did
you know there were a quadrilogy so you
have to come start were 34 yeah and I'm
all-in
I don't give a [ __ ] I'm mocking it I
want to take my money they should just
call every like eighth one the last Jedi
yeah they just could and we keep coming
back the lastest general the last est
jet the for real we're not kidding last
Jedi um what else you got that's good
Star Wars news
some are two for two I like just reach
it will take you no bad news no bad no
bad news no bad news don't you bring me
no bad your boy Seth Rogen uh yeah I
mean you know he's working them you know
you may have big hesitant to claim them
as my own but I didn't work as I'm
wonderful
he is war your boy than he is my boy
fair enough
he and Evan Goldberg the is riding
garden area are signed a deal to write
and direct and produce an adaptation of
Robert Kirkman's invincible for
universal what is that it's his
superhero book that's I think a hundred
and thirty six issues in and going at
one point Tom Cruise was gonna star for
Paramount but that sort of fell apart
but yeah it's this sort of galactic
super heroic like it's his Superman
basically according to mr. Kirkman for
nearly a decade I've had to endure the
what about invincible question as fans
have watch The Walking Dead grow into
the multimedia monstrosity it has become
over the years Kirkman said the answer
was always that we were waiting for the
right team to partner with if the team
has arrived the in steamed misters
Goldberg and Rogen have proven
themselves to be top-notch directors
with a keen collective eye for stunning
visuals blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah there's more to it but its way to
Peter out there it's just what I started
getting good he started getting real
dick sucky
that's what likes I'm done it's another
kind of good fortune of others it's
another paragraph of dick sucky if you
want I can do the dick sucked i yes I
can hear it now
there's a lot of there's enough
hobgoblin so there's a feature it's
gonna be featured it's gonna be a big
deal a deal good more a comic book we'll
probably not a cost as much as
apparently Avengers infinity war will
cost which is a nice segue thank you
why what's the what's the rumor mill
what what are those two movies now to be
fair they're shooting them back-to-back
so they're probably saving a bunch of
money you you would think that's what
has happened in the past they're setting
you up for this we are I mean Back to
the Future 2 & 3 went back to back to
Sony you can get all the actors together
you don't have to fly anybody places the
new doesn't have to be reassembled the
studio likes them like that they go a
stash and then we shoot them
back-to-back
shoot they're Avengers movie
back-to-back so it's gonna cost less
it's gonna well no no it's not gonna
cost less and also it's gonna cost all
the money's all of the money how much 1
billion dollars your [ __ ] yeah yeah to
memorize did you say these eyebrows
raised not surprised hey we said it
before we start shooting show shoot
Jewish oh really
we were talking about before poppy
that's not surprising like what was the
most expensive movie prior pirate to the
Caribbean on Stranger Tides apparently
[ __ ] dinner about three silver 5 I felt
like there was an over 350 movie
somebody gonna get to 500 and if you're
gonna shoot the wad why not on the
Avengers 2 part now a lot of that is
also salary this time around a lot of
its got to be cast because according you
know apparently about 375 for Stranger
Tides a third of it a full third not no
film
no money no catering a third that was
Johnny Depp salary I mean that makes
sense like if you're gone the only
reason that anyone's going is because of
him so it's like look this is what it
takes make it rain all over them and
stuff and boom we got a movie yeah so
for two Avengers movies you got to pay
Downey what you got to pay Downey yes
that's the thing is I don't think a lot
of those deals are up to yeah
and in order to get it done they're
gonna have to shell out and guess what
if this had been old Marvel Studios they
would have cinched the belts and it
wouldn't cost that much Disney Box
Marvel Studios to make 4/10 money
factory they're just gonna pour goofy
money all over it money that from here
to Pluto we're not talking mini money
we're talking somebody slipped him a
Mickey money and if you got rid of time
there's a lot of Disney Revlon to do but
if you got to get all the Avengers in
there yeah you got all the guardians in
there yeah got to get an ant-man you got
to get Doctor Strange you got to get a
black panther all those [ __ ]
cost money and none of those
[ __ ] are cheap so yeah like I I
kind of see how you get to 500 million
per movie you're not saving anything at
that point but you're spending it all on
people you're making two movies for a
billion so that means two of those
movies together
have to make two billion to break even
and that's that's a billion before
conventional dope easy math yes it's
more you know nuanced than that but yes
essentially studio math is whatever you
spend you got to make double to
break-even right because I got money off
with other sources yes I mean prints
don't cost it used to be prints and
advertising the cost to my name is
Prince
used to have to duplicate the print yeah
yeah like go to a lab and cut three
thousand different versions your movie
no ship it all over the country slash
the whip be a bunch of zeros and ones
over your phone line so that cost less
advertising films aren't made on film no
nor are they show not film that much
apparently no unless you go to a very
special private place I'd like to call
my bedroom that's where you still got
filmed yeah films films but yeah a
billion dollars for those two movies 1
billion 1 billion 1 billion dollars 1
billion 1 billion 1 billion dollars is
where we are today kids they spent a
billion dollars on two movies what two
movies you ask to comic book movies
mm-hmm to Marvel movies go back in time
20 years and tell somebody that the bill
you're out of your [ __ ] mind
Marvel the Punisher movie with Dolph
Lundgren was terrible
that's where we used to be now we're in
a world where [ __ ] Marvel's like yeah
and it's not even like they have to
invent new technology it's not like
they're how do we make the spaceships
fly fly through space again George I
don't know we'll invent it as we go
how do we put these actors underwater
James I don't know we'll make it up as
we go
how do we synced Titanic that we have to
build I don't know we'll figure it out
they figure it all out now they're just
spending money on it
that's just the foreplay you get the
point dizzy man Disney's like [ __ ] it
let's just spend we got disney money
crazy disney money I'm out of dolla
dolla bills y'all
oh they're gonna make so much money too
so why not spend it man you're talking
about the one movie that'll make
everybody get out of their houses leave
their couches and [ __ ] your parents are
going your grandparents are going this
is gonna be an event son every marvel
this is what they've been building
toward all this time I think they're
smart to spend that money cuz they're
gonna make a lot more you're talking
about what will probably be I to the
highest grossing films of all time if
they played her cards right and I think
Kevin Baggies plays guards expertly as
far as I'm concerned overwatch and build
the Marvel Cinematic Universe over these
years he has built something that is
about to crescendo there's about to
[ __ ] break the wave of money all over
Disney I think I think these movies
break box-office right I think a lookout
an avatar so far they always have so
yeah but this is it this is the
collective this is like we're bringing
it all together
where's our [ __ ] one and then
everything's gonna change they keep
telling I know there's a whole new phase
that means like maybe [ __ ] the big
guys go away for seven seas you know
maybe [ __ ] many comes a junior goes
away I mean Evans keeps saying he wants
to keep playing says he yeah he's like
you know what I had a different Chris
Evans who it was just like no I know
like I think he went he underwent some
group transformation I tell you what
happened was he [ __ ] made the Winter
Soldier it was like oh my god we can
make these good yeah oh this is [ __ ]
amazing go get more of this better get
more of this less of the first one
first one was great no I loved the first
one I was really sure John yeah but yeah
that baby daddy Joe Joseph um yeah man
I'm all-in spend all the monies cuz
you're gonna take you're gonna make all
the money's think about it we're playing
in this dopey realm of like oh they've
got to make two billion at the box
office to break-even didn't give a [ __ ]
about the box office with a movie like
this because it's the employees it's the
sweetest plan give me a [ __ ] single
watching watching the sweet [ __ ] plum
all your face back a chest that is
marketing they're gonna sell toys lots
of toys to shot they're gonna sell so
many [ __ ] toys so many [ __ ] things
so many licenses are gonna be made for
this Avengers infinity war a flick that
they're gonna they're gonna print money
off of that they're even worried about
the box office like box office that's
quaint what is this the 80s go [ __ ]
yourself
well print money making Dixie Cups Dixie
Cups was this the 70s
they're making whatever they make them
stuff they're making money off the merch
for the record the the plum analogy is
where it turned for me that's what that
no no I did frighten me a little bit a
second ago I got a feeling things that I
wasn't expecting to feel today meant
down below it's pretty erotic watch it
[ __ ] fat dude
it really is juice flowing down his
beard wrench just hey starsk admitted to
comedy i do this as well said not that
much so yes avengers billion dollars for
those two movies good it's worth it
its best use of a billion dollars ever
there I'll [ __ ] say it Rousseau's
please make it worth it [ __ ] a lot of
money boys there's a lot of mouths we
could feed in like the third or second
worlds by proving these these guys I
remember directed an arrest to develop
mmm-hmm now they are in charge of a
billion dollars that's a my kids you
never know I mean honestly I would I
mean everything Patton Oswalt might have
had a job like this where you know
[ __ ] John Mulaney you could spend a
billion dollars in that movie and charge
me to see it or you could just charge me
to look at a billion dollars if you
stacked up a billion dollars I would
ten dollars to look at it geez I want to
see that much money
show me that much money I don't care
what it's doing classic bit I'm stealing
it from another comedian now I'm care I
also said another comedian as if I am
one not true bold flames coming from
over here it's all [ __ ]
plums you guys plums plums yeah but you
made it weirder I sure yeah I got a lady
Mulaney
this whole Flashdance thing happened
what a feeling no babies believe in
Mullaney money yeah I was in hello
Mulaney
speaking of Marvel as opposed to hello
my baby [ __ ] thick and veiny [ __ ] no man
just a baby mowing is a millennial it's
it can be my baby yes anyway moving on
moving on Marv oh yeah again still in
the marvel zone take all my money Marvel
freeform previously known as ABC Family
yeah boy they have a real identity
complex I mean I don't know what
freeform says to you that ABC family
doesn't and before ABC Family was called
something else
yes family challenge ah maybe she bought
it it's been through a few iterations
but now it's freeform now it's freeform
free-for-all a free-form they are the
people who gave cloak-and-dagger the
straight to series order 10 episodes
yeah oaken dagger
they have just followed up with new
warriors which means kids we're gonna
get squirrel girl squirrel girl what's
her power she talks to squirrels girl I
just wrote that on the plus hey now dude
it's that's that's cool it is super cool
like an hour comedy toots and a full and
then I'm gonna burden us with a full
hours a half hour in and out well I'm
another good news show this is a show
you're tuned into we're like holy [ __ ]
oh this is good world girl on my
television sets yes please ain't on you
nothing bad here and it's not like we're
Arden it's just like leave all this good
[ __ ] that's going on don't let anybody
tell you the life sucks man when there's
a [ __ ] squirrel girl stroke
we are in the brightest time line if
there's a squirrel girl or we're in the
darkest timeline and this is what lets
us know yeah it's true mmm oh my god I
thought about that maybe they like here
play with your [ __ ] Squirrel Girl
I like take over the where my god stop
watching score go get off their [ __ ]
line man and God didn't been [ __ ]
protest like in that Pepsi commercial
some cop a Pepsi change the world
yeah live for now live and learn Pepsi
what else
oh no pops a [ __ ] back in the news back
in the news because you know why they're
making a predator movie Shane Black is
making a predator which is that's
amazing now more I've never been more
interested in the predator than when
[ __ ] they said shame bucks doing him
like just Kiss Bang Bang Shane black
Lethal Weapon script Shane black [ __ ]
Iron Man 3 Shane black [ __ ] the nice
black that's a blonde people like yeah
[ __ ] that shameful yeah oh my gah ok
I mean it's like not like an auto
dealership owner in Pomona Shane black
no not that Shane bland not that guy do
y'all trust that [ __ ] this shame
dodgy as [ __ ] apparently though Amish
warts and Egger
has turned down and offered to appear in
Shane Black's the predator can make it
god damn it give me it
they got to see my anger give me a
single Wow now back to to show not
really that invested I'm gay
yeah they asked me and I read it and I
didn't like it so much more [ __ ]
oh what a prick you don't have to say
that [ __ ] [ __ ] on schambach dude dude
bro Governator on the vibe that I'm
getting reading the second half of his
quote is that it wasn't a big enough
role I can tell that because he says
there's a chance that if they rewrite it
or make it a more significant role but
the way it is now no I won't do that
what you'll do the Expendables but you
won't do this you won't work with a
bonafide
great a filmmaker like a shame black my
it's matter with you I mean he does not
want to get to the choppa it's a shame
alright well you know what he ain't
coming to the party who gives a [ __ ] no
my star that
one man and one man only the predator
mmm I remember he looks like this I'm
coming for you big like vagina dentata
face yeah totally yeah man like you got
the predator you got a party [ __ ]
Schwarzenegger secondary when I think of
the predator movie or movies mmm I don't
think about he rarely leaves mine in
fact when you're connected to a Zico
that's right this will be interesting I
was like oh wait this happened to him I
mean I want Carl Weathers a bit more
than I want there you go watch that guy
and he would absolutely do it reach out
to him shame buck maybe Shane blacks
that guy Merdeka I think I got my black
guy I read another black because the
black sterling K Brown yeah but
something this is us but and it was
great it was an amazing actor yeah he
[ __ ] you make I look I was like he
made me think he was that guy I don't
even know what that real guys his
performance was so [ __ ] riveting I'm
like I felt bad for Chris Darden and
[ __ ] like that that's a mark of a good
actor I don't watch that other [ __ ] I
was very good is it
yeah I mean if you'd like to cry [ __ ]
I'd love to die what sigh is it across
every [ __ ] episode what cried more
than cried the flash anybody got
superpowers no no I mean there's one
very heavy woman whose superpower is
somehow managing to not lose weight even
though she goes to fat farms and [ __ ]
this heavy Paris everyone intrigues me
um she's the one I see on the billboards
yeah yeah I see you know it's kind of
sweet man that there's a somebody on TV
that's fat that's not being like played
for Laughs or something like yeah I mean
that is a [ __ ] fat person that's
that's cool I remember seeing her in the
Billboard and being like right the [ __ ]
on look where we are
well tell you there is a comic book
connection now one of the leads of this
show a fella named Justin Hartley
starred as Arthur curry in the never
aired mercy reef television show really
yes he was Aquaman
deep cuts yes fair enough fair and I
think you might still be able to
download on Apple because I've seen it
cuz Apple at summer series yeah NBC had
put it up
misho when it didn't get picked up
they're like well people write Aquaman a
comic book [ __ ] put it online so I
bought it I'm look for it yeah it's out
there seems like something like why why
didn't they give that to well I guess
they're doing the feature now yeah but I
mean this was [ __ ] back in the day back
in his like 2002 2003 maybe um
Ving Rhames is his sort of mentor oh
really yeah I think I remember this he's
a captain or something like that not
good I'll say it's not good but still
better than David E Kelly's one-woman
show which was very much not good you
saw that yeah did you not see that I
never saw and not good how not good
as I recall very much not good really
just yeah like Adrian put how far from
the tone it's it's trying to be very
meta like as I recall Wonder Woman was
the head of a corporation that made
money franchising Wonder Woman so like
there's the there's a boardroom meeting
which I know you love yeah oh my god if
you if you really love boardroom
meetings with superheroes in them then
there's a couple here that's the show
where she's debating the merits of the
Wonder Woman doll whose tits are too big
I think and yeah I distinctly remember
that for a couple of reasons but that
conversation where the womanpower
character is explaining to somebody that
a woman can also be attractive and
powerful at the same time um sounds like
sounds like Supergirl nailed it
Supergirl got it Supergirl understood it
but this was a little to the left of
what anybody really wanted out of Wonder
Woman and welcome to failed DC pilots
with Margot is mercy reef and Wonder
Woman
yeah which are both online if you dig a
little hard not like illegal hard but
just a little hard YouTube social bring
them up perhaps know what I'm doing
tonight all right what's next
uh let's see Hasbro wants to freshen up
GI Joe what do you mean they decide that
GI Joe is not cool it mean
more millennial how does one do that
unclear but according to the LA Times
the minds over there he'll never give up
he'll stay till the fight one GI Joe is
their jihad the world has changed and I
think you're gonna see judge he'll
changing with it said the dude at Hasbro
there he works for a new firm like a
Blackwater firm and [ __ ] was like don't
trust the government we hire
professional you know to guard the money
or maybe they're all like singers on
tour maybe you know aiming towards money
owes I don't know were they military I
mean I remember the tall dolls were but
like the GI Joe Hasbro tiny action
figure line were they military or was
Joe's their own they had some military
connection yeah but I got the feeling
that they were like a privately liaised
fighting force that is somehow armed and
equipped with the finest military
technology even though nobody's got a
job other than that thing
they got lasers too and lasers and it
[ __ ] tanks and [ __ ] but they're not
army navy or Air Force and Marines they
were their own thing but I think it's
like they took the best of the brightest
and made their own sort of paramilitary
interdiction of force hey watch it were
thrown the interdictions around sorry
all right so what are they gonna do
there you taste but they said there's
gonna be a much more contemporary
approach to the whole franchise and that
will allow us to develop different
characters we hope to create a head snap
it's a different kind of Joe one that
still resonates with Joe fans but brings
an uninitiated audience and expands the
audience internationally and
domestically I want this hey hey that's
still GI Joe look at this that's got a
new spin on it
what you're not my dad yeah oh yeah this
is a hipster GI Joe hey I'm in I feels
young again they they they tweet when
they're gonna get a cobra commander they
snapchat their plans or he's not even
called GI Joe anymore like we found that
G eyes aren't really
a bowl and stuff people don't trust the
military's my sheds don't even know what
Jamie we're just calling them yojo which
you know if they used to say that in the
show so it's kind of the same thing yo
Joe yo Joe we've gotten rid of all the
characters and we've just turned it into
this the yo Joe in that fun that's the
new head snap we're making it super hip
we got lin-manuel Miranda to writing a
theme so [ __ ] thing he'll never give
up Joe Wow all right well I'm ready go
ahead hit me with your new GI Joe I've
seen I'm like you know [ __ ] bowel
circle act is all happened before it all
happened again I've seen many iterations
of GI Joe this ain't my [ __ ] first it
ain't my last nope I mean didn't warn
Ellis I think do a GI Joe cartoon like
six episodes or something for Netflix
like five or six years ago I want it's
scratching in my brain and like Warren
Ellis doing [ __ ] GI Joe is an amazing
idea whether it's good or bad and I
can't speak to either but just that's a
[ __ ] good idea mmm if they find
somebody to come at it with a total
left-field play and yeah all right hey
dazzle who is it hit me with the name
who could give us a Shane black you
didn't roll too far I didn't wander out
of this particular I really did looking
for a little deeper than that looking
for a deeper none can't be all Shane
black now as much as we all want it to
be everything to be Shane Black
sometimes you guys cheer look spread the
wealth all right Edgar right hey you got
my money you've got my money sir I want
to see this movie producing super fun I
would watch that yeah we got we got one
last thing here it is folks won the
final because you know how much I love
and I know how much you love the doom I
love David Lynch's movie dune I'll be
honest I've never read the books Frank
Herbert's dune
is for better people than I people that
can read books that thick I am a huge
fan of the David Lynch movie I know
there's
TV mini-series by sci-fi or something it
was there were two of them but I swear
by that David Lynch movie that is
[ __ ] crazy go quietly like everything
about that movie is so [ __ ] weird the
legend behind it that he gave up doing
Return of the Jedi to make this movie
that made it all [ __ ] up and that the
this travelers look like giant balls and
vaginas they blow [ __ ] dust oh all
the masculine and the feminine joining
to bridge space and time and like a good
comic book you know which it's not it's
comes from a book but they did internal
monologue oh there's a bunch of
[ __ ] talking to themselves yeah
and each other weirdly psychically VOAD
you never get this into me but he's
really psychic but they're having
conversations but here's the mind if you
walk without rhythm you won't disturb
the world always talking about it yeah
good Oh what I see is that there are
trees I want to kill remember the big
dude it was just like I want spit in
your face any [ __ ] dribble spitter
face your scars I like heaven to me
so yes dude we could just keep quoting
ya that we can I could do this all night
dune is being remade oh my god I am
[ __ ] as unsurprised as a Benny jezzer
a twitch thank you nice job thank you
ooh I've seen the future I see it coming
take your hand out of the box young man
our man denis villeneuve yeah is
directing I don't know I like his work
yes who did a rival and Sicario yeah
prisoners prisoners yes he's directing
for legendary which bought the rights to
both TV and movies but at this point
there's no TV plan just movies for now
and they hired Eric Roth older guy
screenwriter the great Screen Rant Eric
Roth from Forrest Gump the insider and
Curious Case of Benjamin Button also the
given at a given that they're giving it
a big push a a list Rob are they they
are indeed I mean I ain't gonna take
away from [ __ ] David Lynch's version
no nothing very gently can is amazing
amazing I don't even say that
facetiously is amazing moving [ __ ] very
misunderstood I remember being like 13
or 14 years old when it first came on
the video and my dad had rented it from
the store him and I watched it at 11
o'clock at night and then immediately we
watched it again because I knew that I
missed a bunch yeah and wanted to know
more as opposed to being that was dumb I
didn't get any of it it was I I'm dumb I
didn't get any of it teach me more teach
me your ways more deep deep deep my name
is a healing word oh my god can't
believe we were able to land wives
uh-huh and have children well we didn't
tell them any of those things charlie
alright so that's it that's all we got
news wise Newton's coming [ __ ]
a new dune but don't mean you can't go
appreciate old style dune right now you
controls the spice controls the universe
[Applause]
there it is that's all the news you need
you're caught up man I think walk into a
place it starts spouting comic book
movie information you can also not get
wives with this much knowledge yeah if
your fingertips to drop and dune quotes
and see how far that gets you thanks for
hanging out with us here in the fat
caveman for fat man I Batman I'm Kevin
Smith now mark barnard come back next
episode same bat-time same bat-channel
spawn cast calm or you dude that calms
less Kevin Smith
[Music]
you
[Music]